And now great moments in unintended
consequencePart one: driving
days. The year
1989, the problem,
terrible air quality in Mexico
City, the solution
prohibit one out of five cars from
driving each weekday based on their
license plate numbers to keep
traffic down and improve air
quality.
Sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
Citizens got around the ban by
buying a second car often
cheaper, older and less efficient.
Having more crappier cars in
circulation failed to fix the
problem, and according to a number
of studies, air pollution actually
increased after the restrictions
were imposed.
But not to worry.
Politicians saw the error of their
ways and in 2008 expanded
the program to Saturdays.
Yes, really.
Part two: Boat taxes.
The year 1773,
the problem Britain needs money.
The solution collects port and
lighthouse for use on merchant ships
based on their length and width.
Sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
Shockingly, for the British, people
don't like paying taxes since
ships were charged by width and
length, but not depth.
Shipbuilders maximize cargo capacity
while minimizing taxes by building
deep, sluggish, flat bottom,
flat sided vessels.
Our recipe for instability.
So while Britain's Navy was ruling
the seas there, unsightly
and unmanageable merchant ships were
a laughing stock.
But on the plus side, the taxman
can't reach you on the bottom of the
ocean.
Part three Flying the empty
skies the year
2020.
The problem a global pandemic
straining the American airline
industry.
The solution a $60
billion bailout to rescue airlines
and maintain continuity of service.
Sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
With concerns over COVID, air
passenger rates plummeted as much as
95 percent, but
said airlines were mandated to
maintain a minimum level of service
to qualify for the emergency
government funding.
Airlines were forced to continue
flying planes even if there was
no one on board.
Voila!
American skies were quickly filled
with ghost flights, nearly
empty planes crisscrossing the
country so the industry could
qualify for billions of taxpayer
funds.
Jet fuel wasn't the only thing being
wasted.
Great moments and unintended
consequences.
Good intentions.
Bad results.